ich hätte ehrlich gesagt nicht gedacht
dass ich so schnell ein update video zu
dem video von gestern machen aber es ist
ziemlich schnell ziemlich viel passiert
was ich euch jetzt einfach erzählen
möchte bevor ihr euch auch weiter in den
kommentaren da den kopf zerbrechen was
ich dann haben könnte dachte ich ist es
einfacher schnell dieses video zu machen
um euch ja ein update zu geben
erst mal danke schön also danke für die
ganzen vorschläge
ich hab e mails bekommen ich habe bei
instagram nachrichten gekriegt unter dem
comment in den kommentaren war ganz viel
ja was wo ihr euch einfach den kopf
zerbrochen habt oder auch eure
geschichten geteilt habe das ist mir
auch erst mal aufgefallen dass man
wirklich nicht alleine damit ist und ich
glaube man sollte aufhören immer zu
denken dass diese themen auch unangenehm
sind darüber zu sprechen weil man muss
ja nicht immer nur sagen wenn etwas
tolles sondern man kann ja auch einfach
mit leuten sprechen und auch wenn es
themen sind wie kosten blähungen ding
wenn du musst nicht mit dir stimmt warum
solltest du dass du nicht teilen
erst mal dazu so und jetzt kommen wir
zum update und zwar habe ich das an das
video hochgeladen und hab mir natürlich
dann die kommentare angeschaut und
abends habe ich dann einen kommentar
gelesen davon habe ich auch heute da
noch mal schnell ein screenshot von
gemacht und zwar ist es von edward grieg
iwc dazu muss ich sagen nicht alle
helden tragen ein cape er hat
geschrieben klingt nach helaba kehl iq
back to back da so ungefähr heißt es im
extremfall und ja ich hab dann gestern
abend dieses kommentar gelesen und
irgendwie ist mir dieser name hängen
geblieben weil ich auch so während
meiner ganzen google zeit während ich
das alles gegoogelt hab das auch immer
mal wieder ins auge gekommen ist so und
ich habe ja wie gesagt letztes jahr ich
habe letztes jahr im august eine magen
darm spiegelungen gehabt und die bilder
haben nichts gezeigt also mein magen sah
gut aus
ein wunderschöner morgen
und der arzt hat gesagt er meldet sich
falls sie was im labor finden weil sie
auch meine gewebeprobe aus deinem magen
nehmen um natürlich zu gucken ob
irgendwas unsichtbares da ist und ja
darauf hatte ich mich damals dann
verlassen habe dann von niemandem wieder
was gehört und habe ja dann halt gedacht
okay ich bin gesund und mein magen ist
gesund das hat mir der arzt immer wieder
bestätigt und gesagt sie habe nichts und
dann habe ich im februar dieses jahr
habe ich dann einen psychotherapeuten
aufgesucht weil ich natürlich dann das
abgeklärt haben musste und die
psychotherapeutin brauchte 1 1 1
sie brauchte eine bestätigung dass ich
körperlich fit bin also dass zum
beispiel solche gefühle und so nicht aus
schilddrüsenunterfunktion kommen oder so
sondern das ist einfach wirklich
psychisch ist und nicht körperlich und
dann war ich halt im märz anfang märz
war ich dann halt wieder beim hausarzt
und habe ihm dann erzählt dass ich jetzt
zur psychotherapie gehe weil ich
natürlich auch dieses feld abgeklärt
haben möchte und dann hat er mich noch
gelobt und hat gesagt ja super das finde
ich gut dann haben wir noch mal über den
labor also dann haben wir noch mal über
die magen darm stimmen geredet da meine
ich ja da ist ja nichts rausbekommen und
er hat sich noch mal die unterlagen
angeschaut und hat gesagt nee da ist
nichts rausgekommen da ist ja alles gut
und so ging das dann halt ja weiter dass
ich halte an die psychotherapie gemacht
und dann die marken tabletten und so was
also jetzt diese lieferstopp letten
genommen habe wenn ihr auch wird sich
wie viele unter euch da die blähungen
crew und dann habe ich halt gestern
abend da gelegen und elopak bekannten ok
irgendwie irgendwie ist dieses wort
hängen geblieben und dann habe ich heute
morgen aufgewacht bin dachte ich so ruf
einfach mal bei dem blöden
gastroenterologen an und fragen einfach
mal nach ob viele praktika ob dieses
ding da irgendwie ja auch das ist so was
gab und dann
war das erstmal natürlich 1 tage wegen
datenschutz bestimmungen darf halt nicht
einfach daten weitergeben
aber dann habe ich so lange gefleht und
all meine daten gesagt dass sie genau
weiß dass man es vanessa da habe ich
meinen nach einem messer an ruft den
teppich leider aus zugeleitet und dann
hat sie halt gesagt ich schaue ich jetzt
nach so ich merke ja dass sie das
wirklich beschäftigt und dann hat sie
gesagt ja klar das ja der befindet
gesagt viele praktika sie müssen
antibiotikum nehmen
und dieser befund stand letztes jahr im
august fest lasst euch das mal auf der
zunge zergehen
letztes jahr im august hatte jemand
schwarz auf weiß frau leidet an diesen
bakterien im magen die sehr schwere
auswirkungen haben können sie können zu
krebs tumor im magen spürt man
schlimmeren findung für führen und da
hat jemand schwarz auf weiß und ich sage
ja und nun also was haben sie denn
gebaut
warum hat mich in keiner benachrichtigt
wir haben es an ihren hausarzt geschickt
und ich dachte mir so aber ich war doch
im märz da habe ich noch mal extra
nachgefragt ob alles in ordnung ist und
der arzt sagte ja und dann hat sie
gesagt sie bräuchten halt überweisungen
wieder zu uns zu kommen
sony kann der hausarzt jaja der haushalt
kann ihnen was dagegen geben
dann habe ich den haushalt angerufen
habe gesagt es ist ein befund jaja der
befund warum kommen sie her und holt
sich das antibiotikum dann bin ich
losgefahren
wer in einem ich sag mal so ich war in
einem sehr schockierten zustand ich war
sehr ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das ein
bisschen gelähmt ich war so ein bisschen
das kann doch alles gerade nicht wahr
sein und dann habe ich mich da ins
wartezimmer gesetzt eine stunde gesessen
und irgendwann wurde ich nervös bin zur
arzthelferin dahin gegangen und hab
gesagt wann bin ich denn jetzt endlich
dran
diese ja sie hatten kein termin sie
willkommen als letztes dran erst mal die
leute
termin nicht so ja eigentlich hätte ich
den termin schon lange gehabt und
eigentlich war ich hier schon tausendmal
und eigentlich und dann hat sie mich
angekommen und hat gesagt ja sie
brauchen mich jetzt hier gar nicht so an
zu machen und nicht so ja es tut mir
auch leid aber es ist wirklich dringend
ich will jetzt einfach mal mit dem arzt
sprechen
und während ich das gesagt habe habe ich
angefangen zu weinen und nicht so dass
mir die tränen weil die tränen liefen
mir schon die ganze zeit so halb richtig
geweint ich habe mich da in den
vorgestellt ab anfang zu wein und sie so
was ist denn los und dann fing ich an zu
sagen ja der doktor hat das und hat das
nicht gesehen und jetzt leide ich schon
so lange und es ist alles so scheiße und
so und fing dann dabei an mega zu
hyperventilieren also ich hab wirklich
ich weiß ja panik attacke weicht man
nicht aber also ich habe keine luft mehr
gekriegt hab da wirklich so gestand so
was macht die art stage
sie nimmt mich setzt mich um ein
gespräch zu machen dazu und ich saß da
fünf minuten lang und habe einfach nur
hyperventiliert geheult fast auf dem
boden weil ich nicht mehr konnte ich war
wirklich so in eine kugel zusammen
gesehen und habe geweint und ganz weit
so ungefähr klang das dann kam der
ersten reihe bei der arzt der mich
damals behandelt eure am ein hausarzt
war nicht da habe ich hier das erklärt
natürlich nicht normal sondern einfach
unter einem wasserfall an tränen was
gerade los ist
ich weiß auch gar nicht warum ich war ja
hier und dann habe ich noch nicht gewann
dabei dann hatte ich beim arzt war und
als es dann so quasi als ich das alles
realisiert habe ist dass oder als es so
alles sinn gemacht hat als es plötzlich
eine antwort hatte habe ich nur geheult
und dann sitzt sie da sagt ja ich helfen
jetzt so was ist denn los und habe ich
das erklärt und dann sagt sie
ja okay ich schaue mal nach hat sie
einen computer geschaut und dann hatte
sie plötzlich ganz große augen
wir haben den also das was die kamera
quasi aufgenommen hat das was man am
anfang sagen konnte okay die bilder sind
gut ihr magen ist gesund
das haben sie aber sie hatten nicht den
laborbefund das ist ja komisch da sagst
du deine ist ja komisch ja unser
faxgerät war auch eine zeitlang nicht
ganz in ordnung und ich gucke sie an
ich habe geweint ich konnte ich konnte
nichts fertig sein ich konnte ihr nichts
böses sagen ich habe einfach nur das
faxgerät war kaputt gemacht es hat er
irgendwie schwierigkeiten und dann hat
sie dann guckt dann hat sie bei der gast
von turin ihren rufen ja ich habe hier
gerade die patienten der dritte die
befunde also aus dem labor hier
helicobacter also dieses bakterium ist
das irgendwie so und ich sitze da nicht
so witzig gerade verarschen wollte ich
gerade alle wirklich verarscht
das ist ein fehler von meinem kollegen
gewesen das waren und eindeutiger viel
von meinen kollegen ist hat sie gesagt
nicht so ja und jetzt ja jetzt kriegen
sie ja also das antibiotikum und in
sieben tagen
also ich muss das jetzt sieben tage
nehmen und dann noch ein paar wochen so
ein anti säure mittel weil mein magen
sich ja schon so daran gewöhnt hat gegen
die bakterien zu bekämpfen
lustig ja und dann habe ich sie gefragt
ja heißt das dass das danach also ist
meine beschwerden weg sein können ja das
kann ganz das wird wahrscheinlich so
sein wenn ihr hättet mich in dem moment
sehen sollen
ich saß da und sie sagt ja danach sind
ihre beschwerden wahrscheinlich weg ich
habe angefangen in tränen auszubrechen
aus freude aus erleichterungen aus aus
ich weiß nicht was es war mir so auf
einer weide peinlich so zu holen und
andererseits war es so befreiend einfach
los zu holen zu sagen ihr so wenig
gesagt ich mich wieder gesagt ich habe
ja schlecht sagen sollen ich hätte
irgendwas anderes sagen sollen ich hatte
mit meinem anwalt drohen sollen da bin
ich mir sowieso nicht sicher ihr werdet
wahrscheinlich in einem schreiben klar
verklagt sie ganz ehrlich sie haben mir
ein jahr meines lebens geraubt also ein
bisschen wenigstens malediven urlaub
schön noch irgend einer privaten insel
muss er jetzt drin
sein oder ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich sie verklagen wollen würde
also ich bin denke ich mal auf dem
rechner auf der richtigen seite aber es
ist jetzt auch noch mal stress was ich
jetzt sagen möchte habe ernste und ich
weiß nicht wie sehr ich diesem einen
schutzengel danken soll etwa griffe
dankeschön dein kommentar über das ich
zufällig geflogen bin hat etwas
ausgelöst
was einfach dazu geführt hat dass ich
jetzt vielleicht eine antwort habe und
keine luft tabletten mir nehmen muss
diese ganze geschichte ist so wird das
ding ist ich habe halt gestern dieses
video gemacht weil ich genau das gehofft
habt ja ich habe gehofft dass da
vielleicht irgendwann mich auf
irgendeine farbe bringt irgendwas sagt
was mir weiterhelfen kann und das ist
halt wirklich eingetreten
deshalb wirklich eingetreten und es kann
halt sein dass ich jetzt einfach
irgendwas gefunden habe was alles wieder
gut macht das ding ist halt das ist wie
gesagt so mein alltag eingeschränkt hat
natürlich lernt so halt mit sachen zu
leben und natürlich fängst du an das
irgendwie damit klarzukommen weniger
kaffee zu trinken weniger dass weniger
hier und alt im kino zu kommen und zu
sagen na gut jetzt kann ich halt den
film schauen aber so ich bin ich konnte
halt zum beispiel mich nie auf eine
reise freuen und damit meine ich nicht
nach new york oder sowas sondern nach
köln oder so weil es immer anstrengend
war weil ich ist immer mit anstrengungen
verbunden habe und nicht mit spaß wenn
die leute urlaub geplant haben habe ich
nur daran gedacht nee urlaub mache ich
nicht weil also schön dass ihr alle
irgendwohin fliegt und toll dass man in
unserem beruf das machen kann
aber für mich wäre seit nie
ja das wollte ich nur sagen und
dankeschön für alle kommentare danke
schön dass es das ich freue mich dass
ihr da so die aso sagte ihr seid und
dass ich nicht nur immer kreative scheiß
abgeben muss und dann halt auch einfach
mal dass wir was teilen miteinander und
ich weiß auch nicht mehr
ja wenigsten habe ich heute ein bisschen
fast geweint
das ist doch gut denke man youtube money
wirklich macht aber ich mache jetzt 400
werbung drauf und mit diesen ganzen
kosten liegt aber ich hatte wieder rauch
skate oder verklagt sie das
wahrscheinlich die bessere
das kann doch nicht sein das kann doch
nicht sein kannst doch nicht jemanden
also ich saß da und er hat nicht ist
nicht auf die idee gekommen zu sagen wir
haben gar nicht in der befund frau
wir haben ja gar nicht locken luca
filippi
obwohl es geht schon es kann
ich kann wieder richtiges ach so und ich
gebe euch natürlich jetzt also genau und
in sechs wochen muss ich wieder so ein
test machen ob das alles jetzt geholfen
hat und dann gebe ich euch ein update
also fragt jetzt nicht zwischendurch zu
viel nach ich werde euch dann in sechs
wochen bild stimmt sagen ob ich wieder
geheilt bin und es mir super gut geht
und ob etwas kritisch mein lebensretter
war